with the instructed into someone
yeah
thank you very much
all those in favor please show
um
the distensions
numbers
thank you
okay and then moving on to the AGM on
the 22nd of May
not have to oppose them
it's okay yeah
but Newtons thank you
natural Advanced all in favor please
okay
okay yeah item three public
contributions we have four speakers
Connie Coleman Peter Stiles Richard
Wolff
first one is
Tony Coleman
he like the coax I think down here
you know three minutes we'll start with
you and then speaking
yes we certainly have
three minutes
thanks or public libraries
are long gone
when I started work for the service in
1978.
the shhh
but still the moon in the main library
with aesthetic corners and click search
centers
but on the mobile Library it was always
different
we had two in Factory but I worked at
the time
each with its own driver
and the one with the team of librarians
and Library assistants
who would go with them the day
it's 10 Happy Days
out in the countryside
but at least one if not two property and
T and blue brakes
the attendance of study food
and large groups of customers would be
waiting at the roadside
what's going on and chattering happily
other sports might not be so busy one
Farm maybe or some isolated cottages
the main libraries were of course barely
affected by the introduction of
computers
as they change the role of study and
research centers and took a lot of
financial resources
let's take messages for Cold War and the
libraries found themselves applying for
the job Librarians found themselves
applying for the jobs they've been doing
for 20 30 years
and maybe not getting them again
so they had to look for other
Employments
sadly this is not where the complex
ended
two mobile libraries merged into Obama
but inevitably the duration of the stock
seriously reduced
this was followed by another club bank
and practically no longer had any
mobiles
and the villages we used to visit by a
mobile based indefinitely
but first
three on 20 miles away
but money was found for upgrades in the
main libraries
carpets
nice chairs
when I came to lewton in September 2020
The Village posted a shop and post
office
post box
at garage and magnificent Village Hall
and Tin
not so anymore
it would come as a surprise to most
people that we also have a mobile
Library we ask you this summer please
calling
for an hour every four weeks at the same
time and in the same place
and before saying we do not need this
service any longer let's make the
population of Merton aware of its
surfaces
let's advertise it and make sure to
close the elderly and the young are
given the opportunity to browse books
instead of just browsing the internet
thank you
next time Peter styles
okay
Richard wolfenden
[Music]
foreign
over score there if you have any
interest on items on the agenda these
describe the nature and interest when
the items being discussed
item five agreement between agenda items
part one and two how many quarters
item six
um considered correspondence around your
business brought forward by the chair
and actually got one item that I'd like
to mention
David Hayes sat on my right is um this
is his last full meeting I understand
all right
no doubt the members of Staff
um I'm probably having a little whip
around for them
for those um members that would like to
contribute something from us separately
please see me after the application and
uh
thank you
it's been hard not to follow David so
maybe David
okay item seven on the agenda this is
something I'm sure will be all very
interested in is to receive an update
from the police and that that invite to
the superintendent Toby Davis to come
forward
haven't even provided you with a chair
and the son goes stand up multiple times
doesn't it standing up
that moment
[Music]
uh evening uh everyone can you hear me
is that coming through good uh okay so
to be honest the the motivation was to
come and say say hello uh because uh
first of all to congratulate all of you
who have been uh elected back in uh but
I also recognize there's probably some
new councils around the table as well
that I've not yet met and you've not had
a chance to uh to meet me so uh those
that know me Toby Davies I'm a local
policing area commander for norc and
West Devils I have a write down
Tavistock right up to the edges of
Linton and Brendan and we're broken into
four sectors and your District area is
one of those sectors and that is forage
sector now I wouldn't normally come
up-handed it's not because we're
expecting trouble I have got jobs to
stand at the back so if UNC stands up
human is the that's the sector inspector
for storage so he's in charge of the
sector that you're responsible for and
next to him we have Lynn Clark he's one
of our the neighbor team leaders so
Glenn you cover well tell us where you
covered Glenn just make it easier all
the benefits and surrounds a little bit
is it that's great it's always up to
Torrington then someone else takes over
from torrent yeah dollar gutter Ridge
you covers out sort of the uh Torrington
holdsworthy uh Heartland directions well
you can sit down I'm sorry
uh there so look look I'm not going to
go through the complexity of policing
there are numerous different departments
functions in the area of intelligence
teams to Armed response or the light but
the bulk of the resources are are either
in Patrol so responding the calls and
investigating I think low level behind
but it's it's Rave we've brought raid
one lower Prime
um we then have investigation teams to
deal with a sort of a higher grade uh
crimes we've got out there and then we
have neighborhood teams whose job is to
try and be as visible engaging problem
solving
uh and try to be preventative in what we
do now I'm not I if you come to some of
those uh Council Advocate meetings or
scrutiny means I could give you more
detail but if any of you
um what I want to tell a bit more about
policing how it works in your area or
wherever your your patch is come and
speak to my two colleagues at the back
and we can then sort out a ride along or
just come along to the station to see to
see how things work it's really good for
me for you to get to understand how
policing works because not everybody
understands quite how much is out there
behind those those doors so look how are
we doing broadly
um look we're not perfect nobody is uh
and there's there's more work to be done
but
you are for the newly elected you are
coming into one of the safest area in
the country so devner call with one of
the safest forces in the top in top
three and this patch is one of the
safest areas within devonport we're just
telling you can only give your level
five per head of population is right
down right down there on the national
scale and in terms of the support we get
from our community there are parts of
this country where we don't get that
supports
um and it's a much more challenging
Place actually we get a lot of community
buy-in not from everybody I get that but
we generally get really supported
communities and public confidence
figures and the home office surveys put
this at a really highly rated area in
terms of what we the police and then
honestly what you the local Authority
like one of the questions how police and
local Authority work together as well
but one of the things that we're
probably particularly proud of
is one of the reasons we're here is the
stock price if we can but equally is to
catch the people committing crime and
our outcome rates within force is the
highest within Davenport has been for
some years particularly when it comes to
our domestic abuse theory of sexual uh
and uh offenses we have one of the
highest outcomes not only in Durham
Cornwall but also in uh in the region so
the the opposite of the staff that work
here they tend to live on the patch they
live and breathe it's their patch it's
their Community they're invested in
doing the best and that's what we tend
to get punch above our weight when it
comes to the public outcoming results
but we're not without challenge I can't
not obviously mention that the force of
the whole is in engage with Her
Majesty's inspectorate and that was she
thought uh well it was three main
reasons that was around how crime had
been recorded which is in a a lot better
place I think the way it was six months
ago how we're recording crime it was
also about how dangerous Defenders were
being managed and I could assure you
they came to the northern Devon part of
the region they would there is no there
was no particular issue but that's now
at a much better place across the port
and the big one I will mention it
because I don't think I've ever been to
a public meeting where somebody
mentioned contact and 101 and call
answering and the challenges of get of
getting through and I know it's not
perfect out there
um but there's a huge amount of activity
and investment going on into our contact
centers
um my advice would certainly be is to
encourage people to use the single
online home pay page now directly to the
website it just tries to divert people
away into where the best the most
appropriate person to take that call but
there's still a lot of work going on a
lot of work to be uh to be done and it's
a difficult balance I've said I think I
said they're here in this form of the
ball we can put lots more resources to
taking the calls but then there's less
people on the street to answer those to
get to those calls as well you've got to
get that balance right as well
the good news is linked laced with a
little bit of challenge the good news is
we've got 600 more
than we had three uh four years back so
there's been a huge uplift in our
resourcing I guess the more challenging
of it is of course we have a much
younger Workforce you've probably seen
that on our little ways but they always
look younger than you but I'd love it
they really do now don't they so the the
workforce is a lot younger but north and
west has found it difficult to attract
recruits people tend to be
pulled towards the city and post G7 a
lot of the transferes they like they
like the Western Cornwall they came down
December but last night why we're going
to police here so if you know anybody if
you know a people we are still
recruiting there is never been a better
chance and a better time to get to
policing so if you know people please
pass the word spread the word and get
him to go for it
so just one area I'll pick up on you've
got another I haven't got time to go
through everything I want to leave it in
the middle space the question but the
one area that we are very very aware of
is anti-certain behavior and the impact
so persistent ASB has quite an impact on
the community it has an impact on
perception to safety as well how people
feel so I know there's lots of them are
going in the background but actually
it's what people see out on the streets
and the town centers across my area have
postcovid and without doubt seeing some
Challenge and something an increased uh
issues with Street attacks drunkenness
um visible signs of drug taking disorder
as well so look I can just reassure you
from a police perspective it is one of
our priorities priority areas and I also
chair the Community Partnership and with
Partners local Authority lots of the
colleagues come on there it is a
priority that sits in a partnership but
I would say because sometimes people
look just at the police and and clearly
we have a big massive part to play but
it's not just about policing if you're
going to tackle ASB we react sometimes
to those issues but it's often too late
if we want to sustain change we need to
work together with likes of yourselves
local Authority Health parents schools
Outreach Services
um and there's loads we can do around
how a person feels because when you walk
around it they don't necessarily see the
ASB it's what you see out about and
around you we can design out put
Lighting in Street Warden CTV Outreach
Services I've just talked about and
there's so many factors that come to
play when we talk about anti-surfing
Behavior so I'm just really Keen to
encourage a a working together
relationship they'll be trying to tackle
some of these issues we don't have a big
impact on community and how how North
Devon Storage feels so just on that the
YouTube Constable
um wilker has come in he has made it uh
unequivocally clear didn't really want
to push that visibility that engaging
style he wants to push the native
policing style and in medically that's
where he's going to put more investment
so I would expect anticipate that we are
going to start to see some increases in
our neighborhood policing teams as we
talked to juggle and we're resourcing
the second thing please when people come
and they've made issues about ASB on
your patch and life as a counselor
you'll get the people come to you we go
look at on the system and there's
nothing there because people Go why'd
they put reports again
it relies we rely on we're
evidence-based if people are reporting
it that then builds up the picture that
justifies putting resources for
something so please encourage people to
report it go up that single online home
but I prefer to and the last two bits is
safe streaks so that funding is quite
significant it came into Barnstable on
the last one they've been in got quite
significant funding Street Marshals lots
of other additional activity and the
change over the next few months in terms
of the volume decreasing in ASB and
crime were quite significant so growing
that resource partnership results
another to it a real difference I think
about 30 40 less over though over that
time that money is I'm hearing noises
that that will come back but it will be
the next phase and it will be somewhere
else so it might be something that
porridge may want to get and be part of
or put your hands up and make some
noises because I think there are parts
of your patch which I would suggest
really be suited to save the streets in
the second phase and the last one
because Glenn Clinic I don't mentioned
this on the back is is operations
low-key we're calling it
so there's lots of activity around AHB
but one of the things we're doing is
we're pulling resources together in a
couple of days getting force resulted in
for a couple of days and we're flooding
an area putting loads of results down
and you might say well why do it all the
time well we can't do it all the time we
can't do it everywhere but when we stick
that extra resource into a particular
location the lasting effects go well
beyond those two days we then see crime
and ASB going down for a month or two
Beyond because it just left that memory
with abandons they disappear they go off
we take something around we've got some
clothes you ordered in all the other
stuff we might be able to do so we will
be doing that and that's happening
already it's happened I think it went
through Glenn where's the neck where's
the next one
as well fantastic they go out there and
do some some activity so
um
I could close I would just say as
counselors
it's you know this RGV but it's really
important to me you represent your
community do all the positive
communities and there's some new faces
obviously here here today if I lose the
counselor and I haven't got your backing
of reassurance we tend to lose the
community behind it so for me I'm really
really Keen to kind of do all we can to
try to address issues and try to help
you feel better reassured because that
tends to bring the community with you as
well so please if you've got issues if
you feel I know up there's not always
issues there are things with this
problem but if you could feel confident
please come to either Glenn your
neighbor team leader your sector
inspector will leave the detailed
contact details or even can we make sure
we get back to the to the class so they
know how to contact you as districts
you're at a level where I feel be
Discerning but it's a level I feel it's
right that you can come in and talk to
us as a senior manager so if you want to
come to me it's my so
um
there's nothing else I don't think it
was here specifically if anything was
that other than just to kind of say
hello
all right good okay well thank you
superintendent we've got two countries
I've already educated in English to
speak and that's um cancer hack at first
and then cancel alarm right
Marshalls
[Music]
principally for benefit from Westward
hope
nobody has been forthcoming
but I've been pleading porridge's plight
of meetings of a police and crime panel
with the peace and crime commissioner
herself and she's asked for evidence
that and consensual Behavior recently
together with councilman Doug Smith in
front of me I raised this issue directly
with the new Chief Constable will occur
and just come here next month
we're concerned responsible have
received this money to Marshalls and
torch have not
and with including over a year we need
them in place now with the increase in
tourism
happy I would like to ask you
how we can get this stream funding Super
Street funding now rather than having
this live lead up time and allowing it
to build up
because we encourage another similar
profile
and putting in
upload key
seems to be
a reactive rather than the proactive
measure so how can we do that and as a
supplementary I would say wouldn't it be
good if we could have the front desk on
the preservation a bit of an open
because we can have a direct
contact
with the police and I think that you
don't benefit
yeah okay I'll start with the last bit
we are opening
um the PCC the better commitment
um and and we are opening new for
offices they they have gone for
um understandably for the easy pickings
because there was planning issues you
need to have the relevant space and
we've now in something but it's
commissioned that space is being used
for other things which is quite
difficult to uh duplicate my
understanding is there is intention to
grow to grow that and I would have said
that Biddeford would be an obvious uh
next point I probably this I should or
memory now I know okhampton was one I
think is it Tomlinson the other sort of
Glennon
I think
you need to get through some of the
planning issues and understand I don't
agree I think from Office it's a weird
thing actually it just provides a sense
that it's there that you know you can go
there to provide a kind of a level of
reassurance Australia it doesn't matter
to necessarily physically learning more
than the field you are the bit Street
wardens and Street Marshall story
you know my view I think Street Marshals
are fantastic the difference they've
made in basketball is is brilliant
there's that kind of that increased
visible presence supporting officers
that are out there they can tackle some
of the the bylaws the AFB that perhaps
wouldn't necessarily get the call to uh
to police and it does make a little
difference it's not funded by us
um the PCC
[Music]
um how supported I think on like
summertime but I don't think that's
coming this year because it hadn't be
it's it'll be probably too late to
recruit now but the state for Street
spelling I can try and find out I'm
hearing that the whiskers are that it's
gonna be it's going to come back again
um that's from the home office
that they will approach the PCC and say
we're going for the next round of sacred
Street areas where you where do you feel
where do you build the next best place
to benefit is so for the local Authority
in the families well you're well placed
today and that I think I think it should
be here and I think we've got you know
and I think there are there's some
obvious locations on your patch I think
which I would say you know what that
would really really work so I think the
chasing funding look that's the biggest
issue
um North Devon District
contributed uh and have matched the
funding that came in so there are
difficult discussions I I I'm looking
across I I doubt you've got massive load
of money in the coppers uh it's the
review necessarily so it's not as simple
as just someone paying hanging but look
let's let's go look I think the same
screen is a really good opportunity to
to start that discussion
Mr Brighton
town
[Music]
so my question is actually about our
young people at minimum College
um and the interests of community
collegians how often do you go up there
to make contact with them and what sort
of strategy do you have that's quite
hopefully more in keeping with modern
policing and you know the Contemporary
you know it and all that because I can
remember when I was a governor there are
policing me very much about putting in
your feelings and talking about those
certain things and I'm sure that it's
moved on a lot from then so could you
tell me how often do you go to the local
stores
including different colleagues and what
sort of a strategy in terms of you know
the sort of motivation and the interest
that you would try to incur in our young
people at our schools yeah no well
actually that question it will be six
seven years ago I would probably give a
different answer because I think we had
we've had dipping relationships from our
schools and some for the approach they
don't want peace in sight and which I
think is a wrong approach I think at
least being on site should be a natural
just of being there visiting the schools
should just be seen as the norm not
because we're going there because
there's prepared the problem at the
moment I just went to North Denver head
teachers meeting a couple of months ago
and they were so much more positive
about the visibility particularly a bit
of the college about the visibility of
the opposite that they go in there the
ability to go direct and contact Glenn
your team and that you've got some
really good native beat managers and
peace and be consultant who are actively
engaged in the school we've also got
Specialists we've got YouTube officers
using Game officers who use intervention
work with some of our more challenging
Paces where we can see there may be a
problem developing or someone's getting
involved in primary FB are you engage on
LinkedIn with the education and County
around where we can provide support to
kind of messaging going out the Wonder
one of the really I don't have to be
involved here at all seeing it but we've
also gone off to developing the cadets
we've got police Cadets but many pieces
for theirs as well where you've got lots
of I think the age range there's about
seven to eleven year olds as well we're
meeting uh
there's a lot more stuff you actually
got six years ago I'll be honest and say
not alone because we just went with 70
we just went in and we did and we
disappeared but we we're back we're back
in that space and I think if you spoke
to the Head teacher
down there they were talking positively
about relationships
actually about how they how how that
relationship is going and how things are
being addressed
certain people I didn't mention any
problematic cases no I just mentioned
the fact that I think it's essential for
a community yeah but our future
generations of course that's strong yeah
and cohesion
resource in the best possible way yes
and I hope something to talk about are
are really positive ways of meeting not
just coming in because we're dealing
nurses that's right
yeah
have you got a specialist drug team
specialist drug team
so uh not bespoke we have specialist
teams who who do a lot of work which is
around drugs we have intelligence teams
uh we have a problem with the words of
informants but we have like dedicated
sources there's lots of activity and
with I would suggest probably going
through people's doors
um not a nice way but with a big red key
with all this uh oh yeah three four
times a week across the patch we're off
intelligent space doing warrants on
dresses
Society it's one of the most
the real the people that are dealing it
are pendling that misery aren't they
across them those things there's a lot
of it out there but again going back to
like the ASB it depends on people giving
us the information because without the
information we're fed by that
intelligence that information so you
know of people that are dealing or you
suspect do you think that you must or
you know of problems associated with
drugs get it uh get it reported
um what is the best place to report that
then well if you're in the partnership
world
you can you can either do it at the
Crime Stoppers come to a direct you can
go um the local Authority have got Parts
you can tell the reforms they can then
fill out submit uh submit into it in
fact as an area the local authorities
here it's a bit more of those parts of
intelligence forms and anywhere else in
the in the course which is one of the
reasons why one of the worst type of
dealing was county lines of county lines
so county lines where they were sending
kids down here to go and on sort of a
franchise take over the yeah going uh
they would then cuckoo some really
bubble people in your patch who were
probably involved at very low level
dealing but they use really nasty
methods to take up that dress but
actually it's often it's the local
Authority workers the health workers
a bit strange I mean that person here
and is that information that we then act
upon and then going so at the moment we
haven't got any significant active lines
in our area that's because we tend to
jump on them pretty quickly but yeah
well perhaps I could just finish up then
with one last uh one last question
um the Town Council I've got an office
on Jubilee Square which I I've made No
Deal team that we are surely about to
vacate that you know whether you know
that Sean but um and we're just about to
vacate that it's all the majority social
character it's a relatively small space
but it has facilities there and the rent
is very very attractive
stay here
I've got a horse trainer but you know
it's right onto Liberty Square it's not
a big office but it's you know you could
get a couple of guys base in there no
problem baby look there are reasons why
I can't talk about a whole estate
strategy but there are there are we are
constantly looking at our estate
strategy and look about where we have
for me one thing's absolutely whatever
we did with our stations we would always
look to interprets back in the town so
if you've got is this something you and
you wear this particular location yes
yeah
as well
2016 office they've noted the gesture
in the building they definitely notice
the distance
[Laughter]
thank you
I understand if you guys would want to
hang around because you know that you're
busy but you're more than welcome to if
you understand
[Music]
uh thanks chair so this is uh Thursday
three reports brought forward at the
council's annual general meeting uh last
month uh so the first one is the
appointment of lead members uh so I've
attached a copy of the the protocol on
page it was 26 and 27 of your agenda
um on page 24 are the recommended
nominations for lead members uh they've
been a couple of minor alterations uh so
the lead member for economy recommended
should be amended to lead member for
economic economy and Estates recognizing
the The Joint work of economy and our
the council state
the lead member for Community culture
Leisure to be split into a lead member
for culture and Community engagement uh
lead member for leisure to making up one
additional lead member and renaming
member of environmental well-being and
Community safety to the league member
for public health and Community safety
so your recommendations on page 25 and
I'll come change with the leader I think
want to say the words thank you Federal
cheers
um right I'll just explain very very
briefly the changes uh the chief
Executives actions powered by why we've
gone for
um economy and states the the expansion
within the
um the the lead member for culture and
Lambert and also for the Leisure is that
as part of the active College we are
looking at expanding some of the
activities that are solid beyond the
basic ones we've been dealing with and
also one of the issues we have a little
bit is with holsworthy and so we've
worked in one of the new members for
holdsworthy who is actually very active
in providing support facilities for the
children so we have done that and then
the third one
um is we took a bit of wording because
now it's changed within that department
so
um the change of lead member role
reflects the change that has happened
within that department and the
reorganization of that department so on
that basis I will move the
recommendations thank you
foreign
[Music]
and against
and abstentions
cancer Newtons yeah
32 411
a complete item agency does it yes
board Pages 29 and Saturday thanks chair
so
um again another report uh deferred from
your AGM at last month uh so on page 28
sets out the the structure of the active
storage board in Port counselors uh the
leader the member for Community culture
and Leisure as was uh chair Community
Resources uh plus one other member to be
nominated by Paul Council there's two
senior officers myself and Sean parney
the pet of communities in place number
one non-executive director Judith Gentry
chair so the the recommendations are
that we amend the makeup of the active
storage board to replace the lead member
of the community culture and Leisure
with the lead member for leisure and
appointed forth member to the actuator
storage board and Jay I think again the
lady that wanted to speak
thank you Chief exactly I've covered
some of that previously obviously with
the
um with the active towards we are
looking at perhaps are called Hunkin who
has been dealing with been on the
committee for absolutely departed
um and she wants she is going to take
over the safeguarding issue that that's
the Langford was dealing with and
dealing very that's had to be with and
she's quite a loss to that board but uh
kind of hunting will carry that on and
as I said when we are looking at other
activities for the active board and how
we can expand that and
um and the work we need to do in
holesworthy and so
um cancer
and I look forward to actually bringing
the uh the accounts and the report to
this book Council to show just what hard
work's been going on and what we have
achieved in in the short period of time
the ball's been working so I look
forward to that so I've moved the
recommendations as on page
sector
one favorite please show
that was true
[Music]
moving on to item 10. with members who
work in groups Pages 31 and 13.
potential so that as I said the the
third and final report uh being deterred
from your AGM so this is to appoint
members to the climate change working
group property major projects working
group and the harbor board so the
climate change working group is a slight
amendment to what's contained in the in
the Constitution and that's shown on the
the top page 31 so full concerts I know
Joe media will appoint four members to
make up the working group one of which
will be the lead member for climate uh
and the and the Quorum shall be true the
working group will appoint a chair from
from one of the four I don't believe
Millions the property of Asia projects
working group currently made I mean the
lead of the council Deputy leader the
share of Community Resources and another
member appointed by Paul Council the
harbor board the working group currently
consists of five members from tourist
District one of which will be the chair
of Community Resources will also chair
the Harvard laws uh the chair of the
community was appointed at the AGM
Angela Hicks which released full Council
to appoint the other four members the
vice chair will be appointed by the
working group at its first weekend so
chair the recommendations set up on page
31 are the event amend the terms of
reference for the climate change working
group is 502
subjects at that appoint the additional
three members the working group uh
appoint the fourth member to the
property major projects working through
as highlighted and appoint support other
members to the higher award and
Australia and I think the first one I
think the leadership
thank you
thank you John
um I could just run through him a little
bit
um
now if I take a climate change
um basically there are four Court
members that will actually see the
report for the actual working group but
although there's only four names of one
of which is the lead member
um for climate change anyone else can
join that committee
um all they need to do is to ask the
committee once it's established if
they'd like to join it I've got and all
names have come forward in Italy which
is cancer Peter Haynes councilor Doug
Smith Henson Wendy Lamar and have a
suppressed Wheatley I understand there's
been another one tonight and that will
go forward
um to go on they will still be room for
one or two more prevention to go on but
that won't be my decision that will be
the working group committee decision if
we go to the parks
um there is one other appointment there
and we are looking because we've got all
these major projects going on that we
would ask the lead member for finance
which is Council Doug bushby to be that
fourth member know that we can actually
keep an eye on the finances because it's
going to be a testing time
um it's two major projects going on
which is the environment Center which as
you know we have scaled back a bit
because of the costs you know escalated
and also in the Marine Center which
we're obviously going to be a lot of
work and a lot of expenditure so by uh
Hampton bushby it will be the board
member all night well
um and on the other one the hoverboard
um traditionally this is revolved around
benefit members
um so as you heard it will include the
show of CNR that's the hex and the other
names that have come forward and I would
just point out that this has all been
discussed with all the group leaders so
it's been a United decision to get to
where we are
um on the basis so we're trying to be an
inclusive Council and work together
um so those will be closer heaps that's
a bushby council princely
um councilor Jane Whitaker and
I've asked for one other member to be
appointed who will be the member
connected to the organizing Group which
is the the Western uh
um and Recycling Group they all falls
under
um
Richard Hayes so I've asked Chris ever
to step in to do that one so that will
be the problem okay
can I ask the question we did and a
budget working group now I know we've
set the budget but they have budget
working group betas we did say we'd
carry that work on is that not going to
be the case and the budget will will
carry on we were just waiting a little
bit for the transfer from David
uh the new 151 officer and then we've
given analysis Supply services
to put a name forward and again it's
working with inclusivity of the council
and as you know Rose you're on it but it
sorry comes a lot that it was very
successful you know we said about 900
000 pounds without any major cuts
um and we've managed to balance the
budget so it did work
[Music]
against
and extensions
I just apologize for councilman he was
one of the half of all ones I'm trying
to do it from memory
um so I apologize David an easily
forgettable person yeah I don't know
very much
I apologize
thank you worse yeah can I just say that
although
um these are working groups I would urge
every Council if you get a chance to go
along to the property and major projects
working group because you will hear
stuff there that you won't hear anywhere
else and it is very important uh some of
the things they talk about because it
does affect all of us as counselors so I
would go along for that if I were you I
go along to everyone and they are
fascinating
like
I lose weight oh sorry
believe that you need to read the wrong
Zoom because otherwise we are tracking
men our other countries you know it's a
lot easier we're not at the beginning of
participate but you actually want to be
in the news
and carry on with your everyday work as
opposition track for the independent
mode or I didn't even want to spend this
claim yeah waste indeed sort of things
[Music]
I apologize but
um
okay thank you um moving on then
so in case
yes with regard to property and protect
they frequently are on Zoom just
occasionally we need to look at
downgrade Maps whatever and it may be
that will help the odd alternate meeting
but most of the time hopefully they've
been through private environmental thank
you
okay but moving all the way down to 11.
it's important internal organ scrutiny
preference Supply and it's 39 to 47.
um head of committed to blessed Sean I
have been put up before sure uh so back
in uh January reports community and
resources committee that detailed the
great work that happens at the flower
Arts Center it gave details of the three
year business plan that the Arts Center
has
um and also talked about how they've
achieved National portfolio in
organization expenses we have passionate
and interesting contributions from the
public and after a really good debate I
think members resolved to provide 10 000
pounds a year for three years of
financial support towards the
organization that resolution was then
subject with calling and to interim
scrutiny again really good debate and
after much touring and throwing there uh
the CNR decision was upheld so you're
probably thinking why are we here if
it's being disresolved and scrutinized
uh the original decision was made after
the budget had been agreed so it's
unbudgeted uh tonight's decision
therefore for you is whether you want to
support that CNR decision and if so how
you want to fund it I don't
recommendations
to the leader
which is that the case of James finished
the report and then we'll announcement
okay well the recommendation is as uh
Sean Connery has said is that we have
been trans 30 000 pound within the
budget to last for three years they're
10 000 a year there's just that one
officer on screen fence that it will
apply for three years with 10 posts a
year and on that basis I moved the
recommendation thank you thank you
[Music]
I'm afraid we've that item so fast
I think the chief executive did have a
word with them
um okay firstly I'd like to declare an
interest with great changing Town
councilor and also add a regular visit
to the power Art Center
um I know as we've heard in the report
that members have already been involved
in discussions about funding for the
foul initiative committee but there are
a lot of new councilors paying these
decisions will be a fresh saying myself
included
um I think that what we conclude about
this is really important for residents
across the whole district and in every
single Ward not just turrington the plow
is the main provider of culture and arts
provision into origin this company
should be supporting it and working
closely alongside it to maximize the
benefit for our residents
um the plan does fantastic work and it
offers our residents uh young and old
spectation performers alike an amazing
range of opportunities it punches well
above its weight into delivering a
packed program with live theater music
let's film workshops and educational
Outreach opportunities local access
culture cultural offering is maybe even
more important for an area like coverage
but it can build at all particularly for
the young people how inspiring it must
be to think that performing in a play in
the foul can take you all the way to the
National Theater in London and that's
what's being performed in the powers we
speak this evening a performance that is
then going on to move on to the National
Theater
um the power expands Horizons it brings
different experiences ideas and
perspectives from across the world into
our rural patch of Devon not only that
it also transforms a huge number of
other fantastic locations in Hospitality
into Arts venues
um through its Outlaw theater program
places like taking part
[Music]
launched the northern dabbing culture
strategy if you haven't read it I
thoroughly recommend that you do it's
actually really really well quite nice
um it talks about the huge value of
culture division in North Devon not just
in terms of making people's lives richer
and more enjoyable but also for the
dramatic effect it can have on people's
well-being and for the huge difference
it takes for local economy the report is
full of words that I will build on the
road increase develop contribute support
strengthen and help and all with the
caveat that the councils are not in
charge of culture all they can do is
support your demonstrate Council support
Culture by investing hundreds of
thousands of pounds yeah actually we
don't need Taurus to launch at their own
art center in the district we're setting
up running a capital costs of which
would be colossal the plow is the
chemical Art Center asking for the
support of the council to keep doing its
great work and to expand its offering
even more widely
setting up new hubs and Paul's worthy
apartment and Beyond the plow truly does
help to fulfill the council's aim of
making the district a great place to
live with its own invest in into you and
we should recognize that contribution
through significance and regular funding
let's choose to be a forward-thinking
ambitious Council and fully support art
and culture and porridge to that end I
propose an amendment that this Council
grants the 25 000 pounds of funding
originally sought by the flower art
center every year for the next three
years with the first award coming from
the budget surplus for this year
identified by opportunity just heard and
subsequent awards from the Arts Services
section of the budget where money could
be ring sent alongside that for the
Burton art gallery at the end of this
period funding for the power should be
reviewed by the council and
thank you
pleasure sure I'd like to thoroughly
endorse that most eloquent state by
councilor bright but without the
recommendation and I would like to
Second the original proposal by the
leader as agreed by CNN
I'm obviously just like to support them
to the bride statement
um many people move into this area
specifically but the cloud is there and
um it really does rely on a lot of
support from all passions the
the report that's coming from the Arts
Council has said that they're expecting
um support from the local area uh and I
should have declared an interest
obviously around
um
but
um I I think that the if they're looking
for great tolerant we certainly don't
have budgets even certainly either be
looking at PVC here or perhaps even
County but I think at this stage we
really do sincerely need proper support
from PDC as it covers this area as well
it's not a Torrington issue is it so
just reminders so to fully support that
I'd be more than happy to second that
Amendment
[Music]
oh yeah
well I would like to put a recording
vote on today so
but also yeah
how can we not be supporting it with our
full voice
foreign
that's a great game yeah
can I ask uh that we temporarily suspend
sending orders so that we can hear from
the people uh from about given the
amendment we did kind of need more
information
I'll ask uh station
I'm just going to go back to
um the new proposal when counselor Brian
consecutive by smear
um counselor
um this has already been to CNR CNR made
the recommendation of ten thousand
pounds per annum that was then called in
by Owen s who have stood by that
decision now the only reason this is
backup all Council was because of the
budget and how we've got to fund that 30
000 so it's not open to full council
tonight to make further recommendations
on that that motion is only here because
this wasn't budgeted when it came to
Alberto for the full budget so we're not
talking about new proposals and
recommendations we're talking about the
original motion that was approved by the
community and resources Committee of ten
thousand pounds that has been
scrutinized by our scrutiny committee
that's been done and they've upheld that
committee that upheld that decision so
it's not open for that to be re-looked
out of the new proposal to put on the
table it is just the budget implications
that we are talking about and how we
fund that 30 000 pounds and the leader
has put forward a recommendation as to
how that is to be funded and that's
really foreign
[Music]
or
among the awarded to the plow that way I
understand we're locked into this system
at the moment because it's been to
um internal scrutinism that we you know
we have to stick themselves institution
at the moment but there is no reason why
at the latest stage that the uh I've not
asked for a supplementary vote yeah I
would probably think that's quite
correct
[Music]
we get accepted
attention forward yeah
um yeah burning areas there you're
absolutely right it's good nice one one
thing and you might deal with what we've
gone there at the time which is going
through seeing all right and scrutinized
fine
but obviously seven over a Twist or
whatever let us review the situation
down the line when it's no more about
our budgets because it's easy spending
money whether it's for good cause bad
calls are in difficulties so let's just
press on the list and get on with it
yeah
they proposed by cancer James seconded I
Believe by councilor uh
so kind of a short pass all of them
sorry coach
I'll support that
recorded for onco sharing roach engines
yeah
defined to support that yeah
okay
proposition has been seconded
my cousin Eugene
again
yeah
if you vote against clearly you won't
get any money at all so recorded vote in
place
[Music]
around us
or against councilor um changes
thank you
for Pastor David Brenton or councilor
Chris Wright for councilor Lauren bright
or Council bushby for pastor Christie or
councilor craigie or councilor Dart or
councilor Elliot
Council
[Music]
four against
me for councilor Piper or Pastor
Shepherd or councilor Smith or counselor
Wheatley Paul that's unanimous chat
awaitian effort but never mind let's see
recorded vote has unanimous thank you
we're moving on then to item 12
purchasing energy roller framework
agreement Pages 47-58 David Hayes school
and production report
okay thank you chair and just I briefly
go through the fourth best account boys
I've already is a member of the devil
Energy Group
for the procurement of gas and
electricity and Devon County Council
acts as the lead for the Devon energy
group we'll just give you some context
our expenditure on gas and electricity
in the last year with about 644 000
pounds
so since 2016 2016 the devil Energy
Group has been stored utility from the
laser Energy Group that's a public
buying organization it's a trading arm
for Kent County Council
so ladies of pure energy experience for
one year better for the first of October
to the 30th September which does provide
a degree of budget certainty to the
council the current agreement with laser
ends on the 13th of September
2024. so it might seem a long leading to
have what we've got to start the process
early if we want to renegotiate by the
purchase of electricity and gas so the
options to procure energy go involved we
could carry out full procurement
exercise in utilizing utility Brokers
while we've secured again using a public
buying organization like laser
um
when who matured using the energy
Brokers potentially
we can solicit books from a wider range
of companies books and the most
important significant time and resale to
500 seconds because basically you've got
to set the tender requirements
uh Brock because obviously that would
apply a profit admin margin for their
work and energy companies without their
management but the black price Insurance
balances multi suppliers will be in the
supply chain
uh and the last time this becoming
Undertaker only one compliant tender
without the returns it wasn't actually a
substatical exercise and there's limited
governance of utility Brokers compared
to a public buying organization
so what's the advantage of procuring by
a public paying organization
the public buying organization I can
already completed the next Olympic
procurement framework documentation Soul
minimizing the procurement worker
members of the Devon energy control
everywhere you're here and pick you up
an expression you're purchasing off of
framework
and what that means is an organization
has gone out
done all the tender documents and it's
gone out to people and says what can you
provide stationary for me as
then if I give you these volumes
so that means we want to utilize that
framework we can just go and buy a
statement knowing that the best price
that already be been secured so that's
what framework agreement means
um
so what the advantage of a curing
so we've got public interest in
supporting public bodies so the laser
Energy Group is an object of Kent County
Council the energy volumes are
aggregated across all their customers
given a better competitive price so they
add our purchase of gas electric which
is probably minor in the National
picture and the ladder potential maybe
to a big Council like Birmingham or
Manchester and then they get all
competitive price because they're giving
greater volume to the energy companies
and also any profit is reinvested within
the public sector I know shareholders
taking money out of the system
there's four public buying organizations
in the utility sector all of which are
compliant with UK the government
regulations it's Crown Commercial
Services Eastern Shire purchase
organization Yorkshire purchase
organization later and all of these are
off you from local government they're
all been trading hours with local
government organizations
however all that set laser would require
in the following they've required a
change of gas supplier they're buying
changes to contractual terms changes of
supply for electricity mean costs of
Change Plus additional Administration
and contract management which will then
remove the advantage of a single fighter
contact for gas and electricity and
they'll be switching costs which help
will come soon
so we were to move suppliers they'll be
switching costs this would require time
and resources and this would be mainly
from our procurement officer but would
also impact on significant other ads
such as finance and Estates dealing with
change in the administration that would
arise in such a switch
do you think about how many meters the
council's got that's a lot of meters to
give a lot of readings
there will be a time of any transfer
accounts that are in dispute
they'll have to be resolved before they
move on to the new supplier
and what happened is sometimes it
doesn't get transfer because the
outstanding debt suppliers leaving laser
but while the trans personally provider
thus leaving Supply potentially Skippers
and issues that relating to closing
reads from current providers and opening
reads renewable values that's a lot of
work to timetable
[Music]
years to result if there's issues
between
the both of our experience moving
domestic supplier and having issues
about readings and disputed bills well
times that by the number of buildings
and meters that the council's got
and as a rough estimate the procurement
alone would anticipate at the time being
about half of a particularly for six
months and then after that quarter of
government up there for six months the
council actually had one because that
would be a considerable use of that
person's time
well the recommendation before you and
this is global councils Devon County
Council new members of the Devon
districts are going uh it presenting
similar reports to their full Council so
the recommendation is approved that
tourist Council joined with other
members of Devon Energy Group in
contractor in laser Energy Group uh Ken
County council do pure gas and
electricity to appear the first of
October 24th and 3rd of September 2028.
some questions back
can I ask a question chair yes if we um
go along with the um some of it the
suggestion that we stay the days of
energy and we fix into that and does the
council then benefit in any reduction in
energy costs that might happen along the
way yeah
coming down slowly yeah
they buy one year ahead every year so
some do it on a different basis so it
can work it's blood to the moment so at
the start of when all the energy prices
went over
the council tolerance was protected
because we put we've got the deal from
September so first of October to
September and all the energy prices went
off and we were still paying the same
amount of course when then they do it
then there was a cap kill it can only
come down you could be at that point in
time to come down when you've just fixed
but at least it gives the number of
members of the extermination group
[Music]
there are four organizations which are
public by an organizations that
specialize in the utility sector
there's a rook estimates now it's about
12 to 25 will be with laser I mean Kent
County got us back in the Southeast I
know that across Devon basically
everybody's in with laser I mean it's
not just by ourselves you know it's
clearly I would imagine
just people as well when we say about an
LED company they don't they're not an
energy producer or distributor they're a
procurement organization yeah okay
um so I mean it is a known fact that
again apparently or a username out of
any engine company whether it's a
business or commercial or in the
situation varying is incredibly
difficult so how can you be confident
that we are getting the best deals I
appreciate what you're saying but we
must be getting the best deals because
you must have Enterprise
we don't know that I don't think we'd
ever would I want to say is you've got
the Professionals in the business we've
gone with them
[Music]
but also there's
yeah
I just feel that um
no we want to sign up for 38. well I do
think that when it goes to 30A
or something I do think it was looking
out again because
um there was a situation when I was in
one detective on the Health Trust where
we were in a basket
for this property of the things
um and um public buying organization and
actually we weren't in the best basket
yeah
for one year
they go out and buy the energy once a
year for a year there was maybe a
four-year bill
did it too early there'll be a time when
they get the the date of pursuing energy
affected from the 1st of October will be
their own games because you buy there's
prices that's down to fall
it'll be other times when it's the best
decision
I'm not excellent fulfillment that's
somewhat the look of the draw the look
of the timer but one thing we get if we
get certainty we know what we're going
energy costs we're going to get for one
year okay thanks very much
okay
[Music]
other is any any of that will be true
it is um that's probably been more on
domestic than commercial I know I've got
unsung commercial if any of that stuff
will be through
yeah
sorry cash a question is it good Mr
confused
um
um yeah can I ask about uh the energy
you said we're we're going with the rest
of Devon we're currently aiming for the
rest
you assume Kent is and some other people
and the only reason I assume I don't
know I'm being perfectly honest well
given it's an offshoot of Kent County
Council it would be I'd be surprised if
Ken County Council weren't at least 100
well that means we've got quite a large
buying power yeah
um I I looked at the piece on page 52 on
renewable energy and we don't seem to be
specifying anything it's just
I mean we have declared a time and
emergency shouldn't we be telling laser
that you know we want a certain
percentage coming from renewable energy
I mean I read this and it's in rather
opaque if I've got that word in there
and you talk about you know this is
green washing but at some point we've
got this you know
we've got to actually pull our money
where our mouth is and so we are going
to have renewable energy
um there's a bit here I don't actually
understand where it says laser offers a
comprehensive set of initiatives that
can be used by public bodies to help
them meet their targets
in the new laser framework there is a
second lot
for the second lot of what sorry I think
it's where
one of the things they offer for example
an example would be we were to
or solar panels on something or a great
arrow with um saying the word was the
feedback into Big Red
and get the price spot and negotiate
that for us because that's one of the
things we do I'm sure there's I'm not
the expert on film so you'll have to
forgive me on this advice if you've got
repeated then is to write them in and
we'll fold it on to the um
Devon County Council and they can give
you the difference can I actually ask
you to do that because I think most of
the councils in Durban have actually
declared a climate emergency and members
of the devil Energy Group yeah that's
every one of them we actually tell laser
you know this is what we want we don't
want you just going to get the best deal
in the sense that you know we don't know
where it comes or it could come back
using you know wherever but I think we
ought to actually stand up and say what
we want
okay
thank you can I ask
um when is the deadline that you need a
decision by and I'll give my bit of
pressure
um this this has already gone to Devon
County Council
so we need to make a decision before
September without me
and I recommend that we defer and allow
a supplementary for report come to the
next meeting that informs us with the
size of the group that uh I mean if
you're asking me I won't be here anyway
no because I need a client list of laser
that can depend on them answering that
question okay but at least give us some
and secondly the percentages the
percentage of renewable energy that they
look for because it's in there isn't it
the essentially the Renewables in the
report
[Music]
um
oh okay so okay we'll have something
like 53 percent
[Music]
sure
those days it's looking at the table
which he said to me by email oh is that
what it is
I think it says 40 to 70.
improves diet Mass which helps his name
foreign
[Music]
acts all council meeting actually before
um
for laser energy
um cutting this
um
we don't agree within the timetable to
be a member of this group we're on our
own
I've only got one meeting before
September I can't guarantee we meet this
that should be deadline and it will be
on our own and then when other people
one procurement officer that this
council's got you're going to impose
upon the council
that transfer responsibility of all the
energy providers you know all the meter
readings and everything
I just want you to be aware that we
asked what Matt wants to defer it could
potentially be a consequence for doing
that
yeah well I mean I've been on the phone
for an hour this afternoon to Ego save
energy trying to really well they run up
to renegotiate my business again in
order to go some power and it is just
over complicated they give you all these
new prices and I don't think we've got
any other options but to support this
recommendation and go forth so I propose
and we expect recommendations
and just to say that it says here
[Music]
wholesale prices so it seems to be a
no-brainer I mean to be honest about the
other public buying organizations to do
external you know that's better than to
be helpful because of the shared volume
that they're going with I'm not saying
that they're saying that labor is
actually the event but it seems to me
on the basis of what you've said about
it
today so with advice with advices of
renewable energy so in what opportunity
have we got to actually respond to that
and to to find out what they would
advise and help this year and this is
what counts for certain councils are
asking and yeah I mean everybody
if you recall at the start of the um
presentation I mentioned we spent 600
and 44 000 pounds on utilities
uh you know so whilst climate is
obviously important we've got to also
take into account best value we know the
factors of budgets are under so we've
got our moment what part of the same
councilor AMG said where's Brown
Renewables
if someone has to be a balance yes so
I'm asking is there an opportunity for
this Council to get information about
the proportion Renewables and whether we
can increase it if you go with less and
I mean at some point and we find that
out I can ask but I'll be probably but
you keep saying ask later but more
likely the question is it should be to
feed through Devon County Council as the
leader yeah you know I mean at some
point I think with no doubt there's
there's some pressures if they're along
with us but at some point I think he is
um what the increase in renewable
sources we can achieved I'm asking for
that information I think maybe investing
if you articulate your questions I'll
fold it on to see Devon County Council
and get them and then we can feed that
back at our future meeting Council James
climate change and um all the green
policies
the idea that we are going to bed to the
same as one group as a relatively small
Council in amongst all again in amongst
the County Council you know that we're
going to make a difference our
difference will be within this group and
arguing that that's what we'd like and I
suspect every coach and Gavin are like
doing the same thing and so effectively
hopefully we will get to that position
this is important we need to know this
information we need to put some pressure
for more renewable sources
thank you
uh just following to prove that the
principle of going green
we could well find ourselves lined up
with a firm like ecotricity
who have 40 acres of solar panels and
five windmills in my ward
on the principle that we must support
for people like that
by the way
they're owned by Dale Vince I think Paul
who was just put a load of money into
the labor party and just stopped oil
so it'll be wonderful publicity for this
Council if we're supporting the firm the
facts just stop oil wouldn't it
that's been proposed on accounts of
change I believe
[Music]
thousand
against
abstentions
pretty Obsession so or abstentions so
you blocked out there yeah there's 274
won against the four extensions
okay item 13 on the agenda Financial
procedures approval of recommendations
from all in government ages 58-61
. really intends to go because it's very
short but hopefully itself that spinal
threat uh hold it in governance went
through these revisions to the financial
procedures and approve them I believe
unanimously and happy to take any
question but the recommendation is to
accept the uh recommendations model that
came used to the finance and Concepts
and happy to move it's all very
straightforward
secondary message all in favor please
show
against
extensions
yeah
[Music]
thank you David item 14 uh housing
benefit and council tax support War
pension and all importance compensation
schemes Pages 62 to 69. yeah it's a very
simple report
um when assessing people's entitlements
local Capital Tax support the council
ignores and he walked with those pension
people may receive and any uh income
they received from the Armed Forces
compensation scheme a recent order
perhaps a lot of what we've been doing
that we haven't actually got far more
policy somewhere along the lines and we
can't locate it on each company so this
is just the cardio the loose end
actually perhaps all Council to approve
the policy to ignore income from war
widows pension down forward to
compensation when assessing people for
local council tax support
[Music]
all in favor please show
you know Mr Mr Price everyone
okay item 15 to answer questions
submitted on the procedure rule A9 two
questions have been received on
distributed with an answer
conversion to cancel that support
exceptional hardship fund you can see
the uh the questions that were asked
and the answer
you want me to come to that microphone
um
you can if you want to reply that you
can know you can do it from there if you
wish
or do you want to catch me on on a zoom
I would like to be heard by Yeah
by all means by all means I mean you've
got a microphone chair and we 'd like an
equal tournament we could
Luigi and even always got to sit again
right thank you very much for the
officers responding for uh uh we've
given the answer so quickly uh
I was a bit shocked on this scheme uh
27k and we managed to spend the 1633
pounds 18 Pence
and the teachers will spend on the uh
fund you'd have to do 216 applications
so it'll be a lot more work for our
Council our Council officers if we were
ever to achieve the full fund I have to
ask given last year when there was so
much hardship
we've got the cost of housing red
particularly in the private sector
Airbnb pushing up people to pay rents
we've got food you've got energy and if
we cannot find exceptional hardship fund
money now in 22-23 we ain't ever going
to spend the budget it's just not going
to happen so I'm asking the question it
comes out of my conversing when I went
around the monthly and puttford Ward
for the first time in 2019
and then again in 2023 like all of you
you must have some of you went camera
signal some of you are so good you just
got in because you were so good so
congratulations to you but what
interested me most of all
was the fact of how much the ward had
changed in four years and I know cool
what's happened
and there were places that I went to
when people had bought a place they
moved in
money was not yet they bought a place
for half a million another half a
million was spent on improving it and
there was two 23 plate all-wheel drives
in the yard
and I know
I did I knocked on the door
and they couldn't afford the key meters
yes and three places were without
electric on the day that I was visiting
and I was quite shocked by that and I
noticed tomorrow and the question I want
to ask is of or
chair of internal ones because tomorrow
you will be conducting internal ons so
congratulations on your appointment
Simon
um but you will be looking at Key
performance indicator
and there was over 5 000 payments of
Universal Credit
I know those five thousand claimants
most of them will have right to go and
look at council tax support
and after that there will be a situation
they may be entitled to the exceptional
hardship scheme and my question to you
Simon tomorrow please look at benefit
taker I understand there's 770 people of
pension age not claiming their pension
credit I came across several people who
seem to be struggling and I've done
three pension credit claims so far
and three of them have achieved more
than 100 a week again
so you need to be aware there are a lot
of people out there not claiming not
their benefit but what they are entitled
to and they should be claiming that and
I would like on your committee I'm
asking the question of you tomorrow can
you ask your committee if we can be
proactive in making sure everybody is
claiming what they are entitled to Simon
and I appreciate that if you can do it
on your meeting tomorrow thank you for
listening to me thanks so much thank you
I'm not expression
um was
how many Torrid residents failed to
produce photo ID and turn it away from
the board game
and you can see the answer
is
if you'd like to ask a supplementary do
that
yeah I'll follow that on about another
cancer
um yes uh
it does seem under response and I think
the audience for their research they've
done on this makes a fascinating reading
me
um
it seems like the the legislation or
some massive Hammer that had some really
soft moment I mean what on Earth is
going on here when when learning one
person
one conviction for both of fraud in in
the UK what's going on here it is it was
a deterrent of being devoters to have to
produce both property well everybody had
it and of course although
um many of them came back again there
was still
33 there were unable to vote well you
say possible certainly three months yeah
except of course if you were a candidate
who missed out on being elected by one
or two votes you might have a serious
question that they hang on a minute but
I think those of us are still on Council
of makeup we've been there we know but
that's life
to be nail biting that that crucial
moment and I think this is not good
enough and I think this Council should
and an artist has come to the right to
the LGA and point out that we've done
this bit of research taking those a bit
and loving the government get rid of it
and hope the electric permission will
perhaps they'll examinate think this was
a completely waste of time and money
bear in mind that the opposable stations
had more offices there because they
anticipated there might be problems
and also of course it was pointed out to
be that somebody could go along with the
firearms that we get that wasn't good
enough
so it just was bizarre and you know
thank you councilman
okay moving on that item 16 petitions uh
there are no petitions I believe not
true they're on item 17 we have two
rivers in the book in from compensator
Brenton and one from councilor Wheatley
take cash for Brenton's first
okay okay
reduce in
1984. they the River College
campaign got me into politics
and then one
and here we are 40 years later
and we're not back to square one we're
worse than that a state of our River and
our seas is worse than it was when we
campaigned the gate Saint West border
back then for their secondary system
that they were going to impose
back then of course we were lucky we had
some really powerful individuals in our
Action Group most of all of course was
Ted use of Laurier who was a researcher
of the live fisherman who was going to
get the money he had the resources he
used to get over all the stuff from
California all the latest Steam
pollution
detail that you would get really good
and we took tenders water to a public
environment
do we know that I think that the massive
gaps in our understanding of what is
happening to our environment in terms of
not only the pollution but our water
uh no well sorry pronounce your name on
it yes you did distribute some
information didn't you about
Devon's Rivers really appalling that was
worse than I thought it was
so I propose to be set up a word in the
group it needs to be small it needs to
be concise and need the focus on getting
the maximum information we can if we're
going to take on and then just so fast
water
Southwest water up water
you know we think what the hell are they
doing they used to be a water voice a
couple years ago which was a pain that
was set up by the government and that
would carry any allowances so a lot of
people work here we have to join them
but it was on it and it was very
effective we had a chairman who was
constantly on the television that would
go and saved us water the government
would like it they scrapped it of course
they did and replaced it with the water
who the hell they are and Carol cannot
do it and of course the environment
agency
which right from the very beginning of
privatization and a very cozy
relationship with Central Coast water
and all the other water companies they
weren't doing their job properly I don't
so we do need to get over here and so
the Next Generation because it is an
issue it was an issue during the local
elections it's going to be in the
national issue as well foreign
I would like to speak as well
um I still have the photograph of myself
and a group of people carrying a coffin
along bidford key to Mark the death of
the torrage but it was so polluted
um we've actually been here before
some years ago now I can't remember how
many years quite a few and we've been
actually set up a joint working group
with North Devon to look into the whole
issue of pollution in our rivers and on
our Coastal Waters
um I actually chaired it and
uh the problem was that after Mrs
Thatcher privatized water
you put Freedom of Information
requesting and Southwest water ignore it
because they're a private company
uh you cannot get any information out of
Southwest water we tried desperately uh
they did send a representative along and
the one thing we did learn which was
absolutely horrifying that there are
hundreds literally hundreds of licenses
to discharge into the tour and torrage
none of those private licenses are
monitored or measured we couldn't
believe it they just said well no we
haven't got the Manpower we can't do it
and you say well do you know what
they're putting in no
absolutely astonishing them
um
I think councilor Lavell for those
figures again I I hadn't seen those
before they were quite horrifying
um I had raised this on our planning
committee because every time you get a
planning
application for a larger state in
torridge
Southwest water is one of statutory
authorities we have to send the plan
into they always come back and say no
problem we can handle and yet we all
know that it's Southwest water are still
discharging sewage
directing to our rivers and Coastal
Waters at peak times when they can't
handle it and I have suggest I have put
it forward to the planet committee we
shouldn't accept any of your planning
applications
until Southwest water sought it out
because we are actually an accessory
almost to dumping the stuff in by
allowing all these big new Estates to be
built with no uh idea that Southwest
water can actually treat the stuff that
they're producing
so I would second this and I wonder if
we shouldn't set up a joint one again
because our Coastal Waters don't stop
you know a bit of a bar they go on to
woodcom and sword and so on and I it did
actually give us a bit more heft the two
councils acting together so if we are
going to set up the working group I
would like to see it with North Devon as
well
[Music]
thank you I just like to um
for that horrific report
um over the last four years I've been
working on the United Nations
uh committee and it's some of the
reports we get in around the world are
really seriously bad I mean India we all
know in general but I mean the report
that we've got on our doorstep is as bad
as any of the ones that I've been
working on
um in some of the European commissions
it is scandalous and we must do
everything we possibly can I know there
are a lot of other people working on
this but we should work Junction rather
than step aside so I think it's crucial
that we do have a working group
um
we must we must actually
that's your Ronnie Brandon
well I just obviously would like to
um Echo what my husband said here they
our water quality and our recreational
qualities is a basic fundamental asset
for the people in this community the
people of this country in the whole of
Europe were the only country that has a
system like rehab where the
privatization is concerned whereas
there's no real impact that people can
make in the water that they used or
drink at the moment we have an
incredible massive pollution thanks to
councilman over going into our water
systems both in the sea and in our
rivers and we also have a situation
where we can't use our water we're
unrestricted in what we use and probably
by the time you get to September who
knows who might have stand fights like
we had once before in this area so we've
got this
where they're taking our money and
they're not doing the work necessary to
provide us with that motion of
infrastructures they'll look for what we
need to do
that are doing nothing about that at the
moment they have a disposed person on
this walk on the radio this morning
saying how much it would take to do it
how long it will take and to know who's
gonna have to pay for it we are they are
not going to put any money into the 20
million or whatever it is that they
think yeah and that's ridiculously
the reality that religion because
they're not going to put any money into
it we're going to have to pay for it
we're gonna have to favor their
incompetency we need to be vigilant
about this
we need to stop Southwest water we're
having a half hour expense and we need
to make sure that the water for our
children and our children's children is
suitable and safe for us to use okay can
I just bring Central LaBelle in the last
speaker on this because we're way over
the five minutes that was normally
loaded for this
um yeah the stuff that I sent around is
just like a small flattering of what I
could say that um Louise my friend who
set up for the Champions
um down in
um down the South Devon is encouraging
me or someone to set up a group here to
coordinate all the doors that are
already
very much interested in trying to
improve private quality one of the
crucial thing is to get accurately
real-time data on what is actually in
our rivers with um
um the data that was up to environmental
agency standards because they do it on a
four-year cycle and it's already in
those outdates and
um I find I'm gonna go home I'm going to
send another email around about all the
discharges themselves that's water that
um have been
yeah
they illegal or whatever the discharges
that have gone a sewage and one of the
things that I think that maybe we should
be campaigning for is that that's a
Christine already mentioned about you
development
and it sounds like it's more efficiently
reflecting on
um run on water and see which discharges
please have your downfalls and problems
that we have that say they've been
causing in child Falls
um are going to happen with those
climate emergency are going to be more
and more frequent than a lot of
discharges and just sewage everyone
related to the rainwater anyway but I
think it's important that we start with
the pressure of that on the new
development services and particular to
separate out sewage and surface water
um discharge the other thing is that if
we had accurate monitoring and accurate
information we can send that to the
environmental agency who can then put
balance Southwest water the money usage
of those in the from the binds usually
just go into the professionally so now
which is they've changed the rules and
the final flow to Deborah and we can
hear some Deborah and get the money
that's
um the the fine the money that Southwest
Waters find and put them into efforts to
clean up the rivers
um yeah so people would say oh what
about the fundaments and where's the
money going to come from money's going
to come from Saturday
if we could get some accent real-time
monitoring
and I believe that
they're not going to do that I mean only
I'm a bit in the early days of finding
out what people do but this information
that I've got sent out is from the river
trust and if you any of you looked at
the whenever I sent you with those poor
advice and follow those links there's
some really useful accommodation which I
think a working group could
have been selected with be able to
do Freedom groups together and give
people more power because I think all
the individuals are going for work but I
think it means that they're already
doing affect efforts to put pressure on
surface water and government
thank you I'm just going to bring the
chief executing to give a comment on the
all really scrutiny external where this
is going to end up okay thanks chefs I
want I want to talk about the the issues
of matters that have been uh raised and
discussed this evening already
um it's just the the second uh sentence
on councilor Branson's notice emotion
about the remakes of the group that
rematch already exists with the external
older and scrutiny committee and much
like legit intern ask councilor Newton
uh to put a piece of work on their
agenda this could equally be done
um in a similar fashion so it's a piece
of work of external overview and
scrutiny could pick up they've been like
they invite accidental body new skin and
so rather than set up a separate working
group that that could already be done as
part of the existing delegations to that
committee chair
yeah sure
very quickly comes to renting please I
don't think that's acceptable the reason
why I put this forward is we need some
people to really focus on this and
trouble with external is doing that they
got other things on their agenda as well
we need a group of people who were
actually hone in on the various problems
attached to water quality
purposes there's a whole host I mean I
can pull you into the Rangers and I can
tell you that all the various problems
there are facing the water situation we
we do need to focus it it doesn't need
to be given by watered down by going to
uh the scrutiny committee that has items
attached to there
we'll report to them not the other way
around I don't suppose there's anyone in
the room that disagrees with these
sentiments and have been described
tonight I mean it's uh and it's not all
the money
um you know the concern is
the the the power of that that group
would have
and
you know how they can actually get the
information and report on it I mean
or it isn't being suggested that we
actually go out and take samples from
puberty's tributaries of rivers and
internet ourselves and this group would
do that but um it may well be that uh
that's beyond the reason of what we're
allowed to do
but anyway it's being proposed
by Kirsten Brenton
and supporters
well that's all that's it's been
proposed and seconded that the uh
working with you set up
against
abstentions
there's 24 2 against General 11
extensions
so the second and second
um notice the motion is from councilor
weedling
relatively simple one I wouldn't think
there's going to be any dissent on it
but please thank you
[Music]
County Council
Okay so
you wish us to write to Dan Kelly
councilman that's great okay it's been
proposed and the second of her secondary
Mr Andrews get in the names all in favor
please show
unanimous
we don't have any part two items so
we'll declare the meeting to start 8 22.
thank you